if you read books
that describe the habits of uh
brilliant people like uh writers they do
control that sensory experience in in
the world in the
in the hours after awake like many
writers
you know they have a particular habit of
several hours
early in the morning of actual writing
they do not do anything else for the
rest of the day
but they control they're very sensitive
to noises and so on i think they make it
very difficult to live with them
i try to i'm definitely like that like i
could
i i love to control the sensory uh
how much information is coming in
there's something about the peaceful
just everything being peaceful
at the same time and we we're talking to
a mutual friend of whitney cummings who
um
has has uh has a mansion a castle on top
of a cliff
in in the middle of nowhere she actually
purchased her own island
uh she wants silence she wants to
control how much
us sound is coming in she's very
sensitive to sound and environment
yeah beautiful home and environment but
like clearly puts a lot of
attention into into details yeah
and and very creative yeah and yes yeah
that allows for creativity to flourish
i'm also i don't like that feels like a
slippery slope
so i i enjoy introducing
the noises and signals and uh training
my mind to be able to tune them out
because i feel like you can't always
control the environment so perfectly
because uh because your mind gets
comfortable with that i think it's a
skill that you want to learn to be able
to
shut it off like i often go to like back
before cove
to a coffee shop it really annoys me
when there are sounds and voices and so
on but i feel like i
can train my mind to to block them out
so it's a balance i think yeah and i
think um you know two things come to
mind
um as you're saying this um first of all
yeah i mean we're talking about
what's best for work is not always
what's best for you know completeness of
life
i mean you know autism is probably many
things like when you hit autism just
like feet
they're probably 50 ways to get a fever
they're probably 50 ways to
that the brain can create what looks
like autism or what people call autism
there's an interesting set of studies
that have come out of david guinty's lab
at harvard med
looking at these are mouse mutants where
these are models for autism where
nothing is disrupted
in the brain proper and in the central
nervous system but the
sensory app the sensory neurons the ones
that innervate the skin and the ears and
everything are
are hypersensitive and this maps to a
mutation in
certain forms of human autism so this
means
that the the overload of sensory
information and sensory experience that
a lot of autistics feel
the like that they can't tolerate things
and then they get the stereotype
behaviors the rocking and the
kind of the shouting it you know we
always thought of that as a brain
problem in some cases it might be but in
many cases it's because they just can't
they they seem to have a it's like
turning the volume up on every sense
and so they're overwhelmed and none of
us want to become like that i think it's
very hard for them and it's hard for
their parents and so forth
so i i like the the coffee shop example
because
um the way i think about trying to build
up
resilience uh you know physically or
mentally or otherwise is one of
um i guess we could call it lim i like
to call it limbic friction that's not a
real scientific term and i acknowledge
that i'm making it up now
because i think it captures the concept
which is that you know we always hear
about resilience it makes it sound like
oh you know under stress where
everything's coming at you you're going
to stay calm
but there's anothe you know so limbic
the limbic system
wants to pull you in some direction
typically in the direction of reflexive
behavior and
the prefrontal cortex through top-down
mechanisms
has to suppress that and say no we're
not going to respond to the
banging of the coffee cups behind me or
i'm going to keep focusing that's
pure top down control so limbic friction
is high
in that environment you put yourself
into a high limbic friction environment
meaning that the prefrontal cortex has
to work really hard
but there's another side to limbic
friction too which is when you're very
sleepy
there's nothing incoming it can be
completely silent and it's hard to
engage and focus because you're drifting
off you're getting sleepy so their
limbic friction is high but for
the opposite reason autonomic arousal is
too low so they're
turning on netflix in the background or
looping a song
might boost your level of alertness that
will allow top down control to be
in in the play exactly the sweet spot
you want it
so that this is why earlier i was saying
it's all about how we feel
inside relative to what's going on on
the outside we're constantly
in this i guess one way you could
envision it spatially
especially if uh people are listening to
this just on audio
is i like to think about it kind of like
a glass barbell
where one sphere of perception and
attention
can be on what's going on with me and
one sphere of attention can be
in what's going on with you or something
else in the room or in my environment
but those this barbell isn't rigid it's
not really glass
would plasma work here i don't know
anything about plasma
sorry i don't know yeah okay but so
imagine that this thing can contort the
size of the
the globes at the end of this barbell
can get bigger or smaller
so let's say i close my eyes and i bring
all my experience into what's going on
in ter through enteroception internally
now it's as if i've got two orbs of
perception just on my internal state but
i can also do the opposite and bring to
both orbs of perception
outside me i'm not thinking about my
heart rate or my breathing i'm just
thinking about
something i see and what you'll start to
realize as you kind of use this
spatial model is that two things one
is that it's very dynamic and that the
more relaxed we are
the more these two orbs of attention the
two ends of the barbell can move around
freely
the more alert we are the more rigid
they're going to be
tethered in place and that was designed
so that if i have a threat in my
environment
it's tethered to that threat i'm not
going to if something's coming to attack
me i'm not going to be like oh my
breathing cadence is a little bit quick
that's not how it works why because both
orbs are linked
to that to that threat and so my
behavior is now
actually being driven by something
external even though i think it's
internal
and so i don't want to get too abstract
here because i'm a neuroscientist i'm
not a theorist
but when you start thinking about models
of how the brain work i mean
brain works excuse me there are only
really three things that neurons do
they're either sensory neurons
they're motor neurons or they're
modulating things
and the the models of attention and
perception that
we have now 2020 tell us that we've got
interoception and exterception they're
strongly modulated by levels of
autonomic arousal
and that if we want to form the optimal
relationship to
some task or some pressure or something
whether or not it's sleep and impending
threat
or coding we need to adjust our
internal space-time relationship with
the external space-time relationship and
i realize i'm repeating what i said
earlier
but we can actually assign circuitry to
this stuff it mostly has to do with
how much limbic friction there is how
much you're being pulled
to some source that source could be
internal if i have if i have pain
physical pain in my body i'm going to be
much more enteroceptive than i am extra
receptive you could be talking to me and
i'm just going to be thinking about that
pain it's very hard
and the other thing that we can link it
to is
top-down control meaning anything in our
environment that has a lot of salience
will tend to bring us
into more exteroception than
interoception and again i don't want to
litter the conversation with just a
bunch of terms but
um what i think it can be useful for
people is
to do essentially you've done lex is to
start developing an awareness
when i wake up am i mostly in a mode of
interoception
or extraoception when i work well
is that what does working well look like
from the perspective of autonomic
arousal how alert or calm
am i what kind of balance between
internal focus and external focus is
there
and to sort of watch this process
throughout the day
you